hey guys Peter Brown here with a
gamespot news update Ubisoft has
confirmed that far cry 4 is coming and
we've got info on release date consoles
and a setting far cry 4 will be released
on xbox one Xbox 360 Playstation 4
playstation 3 and pc on November
eighteenth according to Ubisoft in far
cry 4 players find themselves in Korea's
a breathtaking perilous and wild region
of the Himalayas struggling under the
regime of a despotic self-appointed King
using a vast array of weapons vehicles
and animals players will write their own
story across an exotic open-world
landscape executive producer of the game
dan hey said following the success of
far cry 3 we wanted to take the
franchise to the next level and create a
game that will surprise players and
exceed fans expectations given a unique
setting we fill far cry 4 will stand out
as a top first-person shooter and we're
eager to reveal more about the game in
the coming months if your pre-order far
cry 4 you'll receive a limited edition
version of the game that includes a
three-part single-player mission
featuring Herc from Far Cry 3 Hey look
there's Herc did he just strap a bomb to
a monkey Oh more info on far cry 4 and
all of Ubisoft upcoming III
announcements stay tuned to gamespot com